fetterman sues to have mail-in ballots
counted even if not signed with validate
this is a CNN story okay about fettermen
about Federal men the question of
whether mailed ballots would incorrect
or missing dates can be counted in one
of the hottest voting disputes in the
pivotal State leading up to election day
and a divided Pennsylvania Supreme Court
recently ordered counties to refrain
from Counting mail ballots with missing
or invalid dates on their outer
envelopes with Pennsylvania Democratic
Senate nominee John Federman and voters
his campaign has aligned with hoping the
federal court will supersede the state's
Court decision the date instruction
imposes unnecessary hurdles that
eligible pennsylvanians must clear to
exercise their more their most
fundamental right resulting in otherwise
valid votes being arbitrarily rejected
without any reciprocal benefit of the
Commonwealth the date on a male ballot
envelope thus has no bearing on a
voter's qualification and serves no
purpose other than to you direct
barriers to qualified voters exercising
their fundamental constitutional right
to vote this unnecessary impediment
violates the Civil Rights Act in the
first and 14th Amendment to the U.S
Constitution what do you think about
what fetterman says here when he's
saying he's going to sue he probably
won't Sue now that he's been projected
do you agree with him on what he's like
is that no I think I think we have to
tighten up these laws that's what I'm
saying like when you hear stories like
this yes of course what do you mean if
signatures are missing schools account
if dates are missing still to count
these are the types of things when you
say and Adam you talk about uh the the
election denier well I think what that
does when people because here's what's
going to happen now you know how you
categorize somebody as a uh Trump person
that person's automatically going to be
judged because they're a trump person
right right that's true
the labels he's a election dinar he said
this he said that here's what I'm for
I'm for if like in Florida they were
trying to do something around the
sentence he says uh we're not pulling
this off here a story came out about
what the Santa said two days ago I think
even yesterday Florida rejects Federal
monitors inside polling places not
permitted the DeSantis Administration
warned Biden's Department of Justice
late Monday that federal election date
poll monitors are not permitted inside
polling places under Florida law and
said on Friday will send its own
monitors to ensure there is no
interference to the voting process on
Monday the doj released a list of 64
jurisdictions with 24 States in which
the department plans to send attorneys
to monitor for compliance with Federal
voting right laws on Election Day
included on that list was Broward
Miami-Dade and Palm Beach County in
Florida Brad McVeigh general counsel to
Florida's Department of State said the
Section 102 point he's got all these
things here of the Florida State
statutes statues list of people who may
enter any polling room or polling place
Department of Justice Personnel are not
included on this list so
you know DeSantis is saying you know get
out of this place fetterman is saying we
should count these guys that signature
is not being counted uh uh Carey lake is
telling voters go for Maricopa County to
Phoenix because Phoenix is more liberal
none of the machines were having issues
the other ones were having issues some
people are waiting in line three four
five hours these are the types of things
that get people to say if we have
technology the way that we do today why
can't we make this more compliant clear
easy that we can trust you know in
Florida whatever you vote you can go on
a website look at your vote to track the
to see if it was counted or not State of
Florida does that wow you know how many
states you can do that in not many in
many states you can't even figure out if
your vote counted or not you don't know
it's just kind of like did they count it
or not ah just trust us we got it so I
think I I do think whoever like uh uh I
think was Ron Ron Paul says you know I'm
gonna make it my mission to go after
fauci on every single thing moving
forward the next two years and you know
he's going to be doing it which he did
you you know he's going to be doing it
right but I also think there's got to be
a more because a part of when people say
things like Ricky is saying they don't
think their vote's going to count
there's a lot of people also feel that
way I don't think it's just Hispanics
there's a lot of people that say I don't
know if my voice going to count or not I
think we got to get people to trust that
a little bit more than they do today the
last six years trust has gone a little
bit lower in these voting methods that
we have we can streamline that to
increase trust in the voting yeah can I
get in here real quick and I just want
to it's a wholeheartedly agree with what
you're saying if you're asking me what
is probably the biggest short-term
challenge in America it isn't the issue
of saving the Democracy that was a bunch
of Hyperbole and baloney you can swear
here right a lot of [ __ ] because if
the Republicans had a wave these are
talking points yeah interesting but it
did speak to a whole group of Democrats
because they have such distrust for
Republicans on the other hand when you
talk about election denial There's real
reasons that people don't trust the
electoral system there is real fraud I
come from Chicago Obama and I both know
how that happens and how it's done in
big cities now did that change the
outcome of the last presidential
election it doesn't make any sense to
dig that up and keep talking about it
you should move forward but to get Trust
of the American people to believe in the
Integrity of these elections is critical
and a debt Republican house can do this
a great service to the American people
if they push something that streamlines
the process Nationwide and doing it in a
way where there's certain guidelines
that every state has to follow so that
the people can trust the outcome they'll
be more apt to vote and they'll be more
willing to accept the other side winning
if they honestly think it was a fair
game but right after people don't think
so but Maricopa this is the second time
they have issues they did it during the
2020 election right or they're well they
were saying their machines were counting
if you want a republican it was almost
going Democrat it was an accident
maricopa's already lost their their
credibility when it comes on to that
yeah like when they were bringing up
Maricopa I was like oh here we go again
that's what went through my mind it
wasn't like Oh Oh that's oh wow no it's
like no so I at the same point it gets
to a point where people are just tired
of the [ __ ] and and I don't you know
you you come from that so you're gonna
know but I think that power corrupts and
I believe that you know and we learned
that in the Bible Bible teaches that and
and I'm going to tell you that I think
that once you find a way to win and you
can get away with it once on such a big
skill I am 100 I will say publicly I do
not care whatever it is what it is we
all have our opinions and I I 100 do not
believe the 2020 election was fair
election I do believe it was rigged
um that's all there is to it there's
there's just there's nobody nobody's
gonna convince me otherwise but the
point is this that um I I believe that
once you get away with something that's
such a big scale
the way they in my head again this is
100 my opinion this is not something I'm
trying to shove out of the other people
so I don't even talk about this subject
but once you figure like dude if we can
put the president in office then we can
pick our Senators too we can pick our
Governors too I think once you figure
out a way to cheat once you're gonna do
it multiple times in certain States in
certain states of course of course fat
of course in certain states which which
by the way it's one of the reasons why
but that's all you need to flip a house
no you're right I don't disagree with
you you're right but all I'm saying to
you is it's also the reason why we moved
our media company to Florida yeah it's
also why Texas is still winning it's
also why a a must in a Rogan and others
moved to Austin and they're moving to
Texas because that model worked under
covid it's it's also why a purple State
like Florida is turning red because
people are sitting there saying listen
man I feel a little bit more comfortable
living in a place like this but you're
absolutely right again
when when when dams put the blanket
statement on you to say he's an election
denier listen these are very very
effective methods let me give you some
words okay some words that you put
somebody in how differently people look
at that person okay uh if somebody calls
somebody cue that person's Courier may
be over okay if somebody calls somebody
q that person's query could be over if
somebody calls somebody a racist that
person's career may be over if somebody
calls somebody an anti-semite right that
person's career may be over election
denier anti-vaxx how many of these do we
have we have so many of these that we
can put there right and what that does
is unfortunately get some people to be
quiet and say well I'm definitely not
going to touch up on that topic no I
still think the average person doesn't
fully trust
the the voting process and by the way I
think that's on the left and right I
think the average person doesn't trust
whether their vote really matters as
well as whether the system they really
trust or not I think till today people
on both sides still feel that way I
could tell you right now there are
certain people on the left that are
sitting there saying how is it even
possible for Kerry Lake to be so close
she says she who is she she was a fox a
local TV and she's now who is she to
have that kind of I guarantee you
there's people on the left that are
saying how can that person want that
County how is it even possible that this
can be happening so if both sides have a
little bit uncomfortable think about
this let's just make some progress on
this part here and and some people this
is the part if you want to find out uh
for example if you want to find out
somebody that is not happy with their
body fat percentage how do you find out
you know like look for example you you
fastest way hey guys you know what we
want to do what's that let's all get on
the scale and see how much we weigh if a
person says what no yeah I'm a good bad
but if something if a person says that
what are they saying to you they're
they're not happy they're embarrassed
with what their weight is at right if we
say hey let's throw everybody's body fat
percentage nah man I'll skip this I
gotta go to the bathroom my stomach
hurts right if if everybody in the room
says guys why don't we use technology to
make our election process smoother more
accurate if the people in the room say
no guess what you're worried about your
weight that's my concern if you are
about progress let's make progress with
technology as well because we got plenty
of bright people
that can do it by the way you know what
I do like here's what I do like you know
how you order something from uh uh
whoever you order and they give you a
tracking number on FedEx and you go on
FedEx and what does it say right now
it's on a ship and such and such it just
got to the port in Jacksonville it's
coming to the dealer guess what I
freaking love that yeah so I'm like okay
it's going to be here by Tuesday
fantastic why can't there be that for us
to know your vote if it's officially in
the process it officially got counted
here's where you vote is great I think
there's going to be many different
things like that we can do and by the
way
to say running on the Myra floors not
enough people showed up campaign I don't
think that's a necessary uh uh issue to
run on but to say why don't we make it
more fair and honest you know the whole
story when people say uh do I need to
show my idea TSA yes yes why do we do
global entry for what do we do clear for
why am I show my ID when I'm buying
alcohol why am I doing all this stuff
why don't we make these things more
streamlined those are basic topics that
a person will say I I agree with that if
I gotta go to a club and I gotta show my
ID fine let's figure out a way to make
this thing a little bit tighter and I
think that is a topic that people want
to know more about toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
thank you